the next time someone you work with says
I'll get it to you by end of week just
slap them or just say that doesn't work
for me because if my companies we say
a week instead end of day is
better and so if you make the default in
your business that end of day becomes
the new end of week you move seven times
faster as a company which is crazy
because if you need to do a project and
someone turns it around a week and then
they turn the next thing around a week
next person turns around a week what
took 21 days can take three days in your
business and the opportunity cost of how
much more every single project starting
earlier would have made you that
compounds is what creates breathtaking
growth and so if you define power as the
speed with which a thought becomes
reality so God would be omnipotent and
as he thinks it becomes or it is then
the shorter the gap between when you
want and when you get becomes the more
powerful your business is